england felt
very different i've been to england
quite a number of times it has not been
so exciting having seen it many times
this time it was uh quite poignant i
think as a result of having been
disconnected from the world and just
simply
um seeing seeing a culture that is
surprisingly different i mean you know i
think one forgets how different it is
um was remarkable but okay i went to
bath and this conference
was
a conference of
primarily coveted dissidents of one form
or another it was organized
by
tess laurie and her group whose name i
always forget
um
but in any case
uh i was doing some presenting at this
conference and i was doing some hosting
of panels the conference was quite uh
eclectic in terms of who who was there i
did get to meet quite a number of uh
people who
strangely you and i have been in battle
alongside many of these people but have
only met some of them
in person
and it was
almost indescribably um
what's the word it was uh comforting
just to meet them in person right
garrett vandenbosch was there ryan cole
who actually doesn't live so far from us
he's in idaho um he's a pathologist he's
a pathologist i will return to him
shortly i found what he had to say
remarkable um
uh
i got to meet uh phil harper who we had
not met before
so in any case oh and uh i had not met
tess lori we certainly
interacted over zoom but
anyway to be in the company of all of
these people who have been fighting in
parallel against the same
amorphous
well-resourced diabolical enemy and i
hate to describe it in those terms but
the way it behaves
leaves no doubt on the part of those who
have been targeted by it that there is a
something i don't know how it works i
don't know how many organizations are
collaborating but you know we do know
that uh gavi exists the trusted news uh
initiative exists
we know that the cdc has dictated a
certain amount the who um so anyway
there are these organizations and they
clearly share a perspective and they
clearly target people who step out of
line so in any case
something indescribable about meeting
these people
um oh neil oliver was there also i must
say that was
quite cathartic to meet him in person
and uh you know look him in the eye and
um
to just
you know the the joy of discovering that
such a person exists for those of you
who don't know neil oliver you probably
do know him you've probably seen a uh
soliloquy or two too
distributed on twitter
but he's really he's really a lovely
person but in any case i just wanted to
give a few
of the insights
from the conference
i think the one that struck me most
was hearing from people who have been
vaccine injured being able to talk to
them privately so they were
presentations but you know also being
able to talk to these people privately
and just get a sense not only for what
they've been through
um medically
but maybe even more importantly what
they have been through in the aftermath
of
having their injuries
like socially yes
and
i think you know there are a lot of
things about this last
year that have been
utterly jaw-dropping but i think the one
that sticks with me most the thing that
i am going to have the hardest time
uh forgetting
is
the gaslighting of people who did what
they were asked to do
and were injured in the process
now let's say and then we
were
treated as despicable
liars or
or
non-existent
right right how how how dare you have
been injured how dare you talk about it
how dare you
bring this to anyone's attention don't
you see that you're part of the problem
right and and the insanity is so deep
that in general one of the things that
these people most frequently hear is
that they are anti-vaxxers right these
are people who took the vaccine and were
injured by it and then are accused of
being
anti-vaxxers
they are effectively denied care they're
told that it's in their minds they're
doctors who do know how to treat them
paul america in particular
um
[Music]
delivers a very compelling i mean you
know tears in his eyes he says i'm faced
with these people
i know how to treat them but i'm not
allowed to right his hands have been
tied to hear that story
i guess the point is
what kind of civilization i mean even
let's say that the vaccines were
exceedingly safe right and the
occasional person got severely injured
right as far as i'm concerned that
person
is
a hero right they got the the short
straw in a thing that they did for
everybody everybody did their part these
people came up with a short straw they
are entitled to an extraordinary level
of care they are entitled to better care
than most people have because their
injury comes from doing something they
participated in something that was
ostensibly to
foster our collective well-being you
know it feels a little bit maybe this is
a bad analogy but as you're talking it
reminds me of um how vietnam vets were
treated when they came back it's exactly
the thought right you sign up because
your government says your country needs
you
something terrible happens to you you
need care you come back you can't your
mind doesn't accept that you are now at
peace and
you can't live a normal life
how is it that these people are not
receiving extraordinary care and why do
we not compare
how these people are treated like all
sorry all war vets but i re the vietnam
war vets were treated particularly
brutally but
because society had no patience for that
war by the end right right
but nonetheless it seems to me that at
the point on the front end of their
recruiting effort where they're saying
hey your country needs you sign up it's
really important right the first
question ought to be well how are you
going to treat me if it doesn't go well
yeah what happens if what happens if i
do what you say and i end up severely
harmed by it are you still going to be
there and if the answer that question is
no then the answer is sorry that's not
the deal yeah if my country needs me
then my country should take care of me
if it doesn't go well right right and so
these people
responded to the call these people now
you're talking about the people
the vaccine responded to the call and
frankly
if you
we are going to be blamed despite the
fact that you and i are
vaccine enthusiasts that a book written
before covet happened lists vaccines as
one of the three great medical
discoveries
right though that's who we are and we're
demonized as anti-vaxxers right how many
anti-vaxxers do you create when you
injure people with a vaccine and then
pretend they're not hurt right how many
people is that going to drive rightly
drive away analytically drive away i'd
be crazy if they're lying about this
what else are they lying about right and
if they're treating me like this over
what is happening now
who else has experienced what that i
don't know about yes
it's very very safe really
totally safe yes totally safe and if it
turns out that it hurts me does that
mean you that you will then take care of
me no we're gonna treat you like garbage
right it's like yeah i i can't believe
that we can't just simply see how the
dots connect right so
i guess i i am
beyond fed up right the the gaslighting
of people who spoke up was terrible the
gaslighting of people who did what they
were asked and were harmed by it and
some of them severely harmed right that
is unconscionable it's unconscionable
and
i guess i would ask others right those
who just wish this topic would go away
are you okay with that right yeah maybe
you took the vaccine maybe it went well
are you okay with people who made the
same choice that you did and will never
live a normal life again being treated
like this by the governments that ask
them to do it that ask you to do it
you're really okay with that i can't
imagine how you could be
um so there's that
i will also say i think ryan cole the
pathologist
has a special role to play and i'm
troubled that there seems to be only one
of him
right only one pathologist who is
speaking publicly about what he's saying
right now maybe i'm wrong about that but
i haven't when you were talking to me is
you know you just came home yesterday um
as you know yes
um but when you were trying to when you
were sort of giving me a quick overview
of of of what you had seen and
experienced and everything there
my question to you was where are all the
other pathologists right and i don't
think we know the answer to that
question um it is especially troubling
you know it could be that you wouldn't
the pathologists aren't seeing anything
aren't seeing anything yet but that
can't be right right so what is i don't
i don't know what degree you're free to
talk about what you understand from dr
cole well if if you are you might share
something so for those of you who
haven't thought about what a pathologist
is a pathologist is a
doctor who sees
specimens
but not patience right this is somebody
whose specialty is look i hope ryan if i
have this slightly wrong that you'll uh
gently reach out and i will correct it
but um that basically the point is this
is you know how a radiologist is a
doctor you never see the doctor looks at
the scans or the mris or whatever it is
that you've got and says aha that shadow
there is a something or other well the
pathologist is somebody who's looking
it's like blood cultures and tissue
cultures cultures biopsies all sorts of
stuff so they see this and what this
means
for a pathologist you know
brian cole has
many years of experience behind the
microscope right he's there for the
beginning of kovid he's there for
the vaccine program and what he's doing
he's and he's there decades before right
like i don't know how old he is but at
least like many many years many years
before
so
in that time you will see
transitions in how many of this type of
cancer you see and that type of cancer
and this type of dysfunction that type
of dysfunction and so the point is this
is a doctor who sees way more patients
than most so if a doctor you know
because he doesn't see whole people he
sees samples right exactly and so you
know he has a much larger data set than
most people do and he's in a position to
see change in a way that if you were a
doctor in an office seeing patients you
might see that change but you wouldn't
necessarily know whether it was noise
right it's just a sample size is lower
it's just harder than that just harder
to know right so he's seeing all these
things including
lots of cancers very sudden cancers
right cancers that were dormant and then
suddenly are in stage four this kind of
thing
um you know and
he is
profoundly altered by
looking at the change in what patients
are facing and his own profession and
their
ignoring of these patterns which
i don't know what we do about it because
with one pathologist it's very hard for
this point to be successfully made
but
it's a very
his report is very stark
and it is consistent with the other
doctors right there's a lot of doctors
at this conference including you know so
did you did you specify the the timing
maybe i was thinking about something
else you were saying but do you specify
are you free to specify the timing of
when he starts seeing
an explosion of of of cancers i don't
think i know although he has spoken
about it publicly there's actually um
an interview clip that people will
probably have seen on twitter where he's
seated i believe he's seated with books
behind him and he is discussing these
cancers that he is suddenly seeing
emerge so the question is is this
attributable to covid or vaccines or
both
um i believe well
i'm going to leave that to ryan i'm
going to interview him but
yeah fabulous yeah no i think it's a
it's a must do um he is certainly seeing
a lot of pathology that he believes is
vaccine in nature and he would be in a
position to know because the difference
between 2020 and 2021 is the vaccines
[Music]